foreign
this is Stephen wall coming from the
Department of pathology waveform school
of medicine this year I'm also had a
privilege of serving as the president of
the American
Association for clinical chemistry this
afternoon my talk will be focus on
pharmacogenomics and pharmaceutical
metabolomics for personalized medicine
for that I like to propose three
objectives the first one is to share
with you the modify central dogma of
molecular biology called mixed
biomarkers
according to the Institute of medicine
report and also briefly talk about
personalized medicine
secondly I'd like to focus on
pharmacogenomic principle to other
sectors for individualized therapy and
finally
to show you some example of how to apply
pharmacogenomics for drug therapy and
toxicology
as we know the central dogma of
molecular biology shows
DNA translate into proteins and into
metabolizes
and recently in a workshop that I
attended uh several years ago in May 4th
Dr Jerry Hawkins show an updated version
of the central dogma showing that
there is a bi-directional relationship
between protein and DNA there is a
feedback mechanism further
protein to around a
and RNA to DNA which has been asserted
previously and also the possible
bi-directional interaction of metabolite
to DNA and RNA as a result of this
current understanding we can perhaps
Envision the possible interaction of the
genome transcriptomes podiums and
metabolomes and as a result this
interaction we will develop we will get
well from drug therapy and so forth so
it's a bladder intriguing updated
version of central dogma of molecular
biology and as such it offers a lot of
prospect also possibility opportunity
for research or translational science to
clinical testing and so forth foreign
biology we capture the previous
PowerPoint showing the bi-directional
relationship and this is a international
interrelationship like proposed
yesterday and saying that how we relate
to the practice or personalized medicine
in other words in the era of genomic and
also other kind of molecular medicine we
understand that genomic uh the study
example or from genomics and transient
tonic proteomics and also with the
problem it would allow us to use the
omic spiral marker to achieve better
efficacy as indicate in the practice of
personalized medicine in addition we
also understand our colleagues in
theology always advances the use of
molecular Imaging additionally we
understand the contribution of
and as well as microbiome and all this
combinational
approaches or who makes biomapper marker
Imaging and so forth are enabling us to
help the practice of personalized
medicine and also increase efficacy
because we interpret uh based on this
concept in particular drug therapy so
this every diagram shows the drugs upon
taken by the patient will be ingested
and then it will be uh partitioning the
plasma compartment and circulated to
liver kidneys and other positive body
so in the center of the power on one
cell is the possible relationship
example of the
variable expression of the protein
Transporters and as such this will
affect bioavailability of the drug and
when the drugs is being transported to
liver for food and Metabolism then the
metabolism enzymes such as p450 their
variation
genetic variation will affect how drugs
are being metabolized and the drugs are
also being transported to the
receptacite the reception sensitivity
also would
detail how a patient will respond to
doctor therapy
and we also understand
in the future is really a combination of
the body only
genomic and also metabolic backup of the
patient along with
pharmacokinetics that would govern how a
patient a person responded drug therapy
currently we have a lot more information
about the role of drug metabolic and
enzyme on drug therapy
as such we can build problems in a very
simplistic way our PowerPoint previously
presented by Dr Bill Evans and McLeod
describing the relationship of Plymouth
genomics to drug therapy I modified it
to add to it the additional factor of
proteomics and the developments so in
this regard
for a good location
Circle in the inside the blue area
most of these patients with response and
therefore
they will be going to work perhaps on
customize working under infants drops or
driving to work hundred infrastructure
so the outcome of this group to group 2
is really influenced by the genomic
pickup
as well as the metabolism
a selected number of individuals will
not be able to respond correctly and
some of them might even demonstrate
toxicity so the outcome of patients
are going to group one
and that is their generation
metabolism such that they're not able to
respond or become toxic
and finally some of this individual from
group one group two my sub come to drug
testoster City and therefore we can
interpret their mentality maybe
influence partially by the
so it's a simple Right Way simplified
way of trying to appreciate the role of
genetic proteomics and metabolometers in
the outcome of drug therapy and toxicity
so we can Define personalized medicine
as we fight on and more appropriately
for the folks practicing in your
laboratory medicine and then other pay
the possible projects enhanced by using
personalized laboratory medicine that is
using only Power markers to identify the
right patient Target coming up the right
diagnosis started using pharmaceutical
metabolomic biomarkers and then next
symbol with the writer treatment Target
and Away dose at the right time and a
very simplified way of defining personal
medicine with five hours
we are learning uh how to use open
expand marker and more recently in a
report by The Institute of medicine that
was presented
in 2012 and the report it was focusing
on evolution of translational omics
Lessons Learned and the path forward
the summary of this particular report
show the omics as molecular National
discipline will include genomic transcam
targets proteomics
epidemics and others does as of 2012
according to the Institute of Management
report molecular measurement is much
more encompassing much more sold by
including
entities such as proteomics and
particular moment
and the use of elements is quite
different from other medical
Technologies
uh it supposed to be receiving a
regulatory oversight and oftentimes it's
only about Marketplace are developed in
the epidemic sector and technically
called the left developed test
and the biological rationale may be
difficult to Define as well complexity
it often carry with high expectations
in this report The Islander kinetic
development and evaluation in two stages
firstly I recognize the two stages of
Discovery and task validation and
further in demonstrating the utility the
candidate object-based tests from the
research laboratory is then transferred
to a clear a clear certified Clinical
Laboratory for development of the
technical testing methods and this is a
very important
recommendation a one that the colleagues
in The Clinical Laboratory and held in
the process
so let's now look at what do we mean by
Pharma genomics maybe defined as a
scientific and clinical discipline that
uses genetic information to predict the
efficacy and toxicity of a drug and to
identify responders and non-responders
who was the plenary lecturer in the 2012
aacc at the beginning Dr Greene would
like to express his opinion that the
genomic medicine practices ahead and
further after cancer is most likely the
second
low-hanging Crystal to speak or genomic
medicine that is using genomic
information for drug therapy so
pharmacogenomic is a very uh very
applicable part of genomic Mass being
number two according to Dr group
or the word where Did We Stand and
according to an article by cop today
which stands for comes from the College
of American morphologist in 2013 it has
a very nice article talking about
building the case for pharmaceutical
genomics in this article we referred to
the great effort by Dr Michael labasada
vulnerable University and in the second
paragraph it talks about
foreign
which stands for pharmacronomics
resource or enhance decisions in care
and treatment
and several years ago Dr Marcus Sutter
already used this program
for Warframe playbacks and other drugs
and last year we would have a third
expanded program to improve Pharma
genomic for the drugs such as including
FK 506 last year
an entire area of increasing interest is
medical bonding and this one shows in
2012 NIH news release
announcing new programs in metabolomic
in this release
they propose
to destroy metabolomic as follow firstly
metabolone may be characterized as a sum
of all metabolizing any human model
and is a form of chemical readout
of the state of health of the cell or
body this information about nutrition
infection health and disease status and
it's also involved in the study of
primary and secondary metabolites and
also can include endogenous and
exogeness metabolize such as plants
drugs and environmental antenna the
prevailing metatronic technologies will
improve a lot of chromatography and mass
Optometry as well as M and R there are
three regional centers established and
there are Metabolic Research and
training programs available
to show you how tiny this topic is in
the early reading of the asms coming up
pretty soon there is a planning address
in one of the copy Workshop by Dr
Richard Jones from University of Florida
please notice Dr yo we talk about
reflection on nearly 40 Years of
Designing using mass spectrometry
systems and he also serves as the
co-director of the southeast Center for
integrated methodology so we can see
these fields rapidly naturally quickly
so together we are not going back to a
previous slide showing the relationship
of how genomic audiomics and Metabolism
combined
in combination with it will enable us to
get a better understanding on drugs
so by the way of example I will improve
several drug 13. uh the first one would
be carbon recipe
the second one is Europe and planets I
will not be talking about poker 4 very
much but I will also spend more time on
pain management blood therapy followed
by a quick summary on the use of
damaging notice for immunosuppressants
so
why interest why are their interests in
the use of Pharmaceutical
s and other antibiotics and this is due
to a very Sophia
side effects toxic epidermal necrosis
Steven Johnson syndrome and the work by
Dr Chen years ago established the
linkage of sjst and
with HLA B Star 1502 recently Dr Chen
published another article in manager
2011.
and in this article
he demonstrated how to prevent carbon
mesopine induced
1502 in this study Dr Chen included
4877 patients they have not been
prescribed in carbonated and they were
genotype for HLA
and about 7.7 percent
repositive for the mutation and we're
not given must not given how the
mesopians but rather other medications
and resulting in about 92 percent
enrollment being given admissions two
weeks later
some integers were conducted for
symptoms
and for the patients
who
were HIV star 1502 negative there was no
their side effects and my reaction was
observed in about 4.3 percent of these
four thousand some patients widespread
fresh above 0.9 percent
compare to the historical prevalence of
about 0.23 so the
study concluded that it was possible to
avoid having acipine Associated hos B
Star 50 node 2
sjsdn been sentence by screening the
patient with these mutations
so this now has become a standard
practice especially in the properties
for the treatment of
antibiotics therapy
the next area is rather
converging and also
rather uh rather controversial at the
same time that is the use of
pharmacogenomics for Warfare whatever
must we know is an anti on part occasion
with no index and a large
inter-individual variation the active
form of Warframe CS Warframe which is
readily metabolized by zip2c9
regimen
has been proposed it's really dependent
on the genotype or the c2c9 and Micron
C1 which stands for vitamin K
epoxy reductase complex protein 1.
those durability is depending on c2c9
genotype
uh and up also on the micro SIM one the
mean dose or patient will apply for C1
star2
R is being stratified according to the
genotype whether it be a a b or BB would
be corresponding dosage of about 2.7 4.8
and 6.1 milligrams per day
and it don't say it's adjustment is
being opposed
for patients who have shown to be c2c9
Star 50 staff in genotype autistic data
along the ways Ray and other factors
will come for about 55 percent of the
dosage variations
and recently an un article from cap
today looked at Warframe final economics
and characterize it as a long-running
game as shown by the settlement
expressed by some of the folks being
interviewed
and a recent study seemed to show
further advice on the visibility
and this is a study of being led by Dr
Larissa hello is from the University of
Illinois in Chicago and was published
last year in pharmacotherapy the study
title is to extend the feasibility of
implementing a comprehensive Warframe
pharmacogenetic surface
and it focuses on the process and
procedural visibility the procedure
involved firstly approval by the task
force and pnd committee and informatic
is being embedded to trigger Advantium
Council
and finally the genotyping result was
designed to be available fairly quickly
so that it can be used for dosage
adjustment the genotyping
uses a new sensor platform
by genotyping right or C1
2c9 as well as zip4f2
and the center system was shown in
Pharma genomics alert to recognition
advising them that pharmaceutic service
is readily available if you want to
consult with the surface
indeed our study it shows the
relationship of three key clinical
Department working together
to All Families service it offer and its
predependence on Pharmacy
medicine and molecular topology
Pharmacy and Medicine together they will
generally providing Pharmaceuticals
which in Pharmacy monitor pathology they
will initiate the initial communication
regarding the appropriateness of genetic
test order and follow through a third
communication once the genetic test
results are available
interrelationship of the three
departments to make this visible
table one shows the functions and
responsibility of the Pharma genetic
Council service
and this service will be responsible for
selecting the genotyping of pathology
validating genetic tests building the
information technology
coordinate and provide educations
providing consultative services
serving as information resources and
exploring methods to improve blood flow
and finally examine the user ancestry
specific dosing models
chapter 3 from this study through the
timeline of the workflow and procedure
of the Warframe from genetic
consultation service EHR stands for
electronic health record on day one
initiating Warframe holder to crypto
doses are just based on other vectors of
rate and sex genotyping was ordered in
day one and the common genetic answer
was also ordered
day two
are solid other than the beginning of
day two genotyping result would be
available and the patient will received
by the clinicians will not will be
placed in the electronic health records
therefore multiple dozing recommendation
also provided
day three our genetic surface follows
the patient and suggests digital dose is
something stable dose attending or
discharge
so the left foot include the initial six
months of study and having include about
436 genotyping console oh this one here
only
190 144 were judged to be appropriate
246 were inappropriate due to various
reasons such as the patient having
received one from our side or another
institution the previous Plymouth
genetics was being done already missed
the blood collection and so forth out
appropriate individual selected 65
was were not approached 20 were
discharged early so the study end up
with roughly about 105 patients and all
these 105 patients 80 patients were
involved
and this one shows the Warframe
genotyping information page for
showing the patient the rest terminology
why genotyping was done and how may they
be used and what they follow up should
be
table 2 showed the characteristic of the
Hidden subject the mean age is about 15.
about 43 female
and the predominant uh patients are
characterized as African Americans
and the Warfare indication are due to
DVT
pulmonary and Amazons and cardio
disorders
the genotyping results show three main
areas icon C1
2c9 and also for F2
and the study showed that the prevalence
of this four of these three genotyping
are very similar to General populations
the result then indicated in the medium
time
from the initial console is about 14
hours and 89 percent
within 24 hours Chino climbing results
was available within 26 hours
with about 76 available prior to the
second dose the medium liquid state of
this patient group was about 5.5 days
353 Jonesborough foundations was offered
and next signal
shows the initial six month that 73 dose
ordered by pioneering team were within
0.3 milligram by Pharma genomic surface
the patient adhere to the dose showing
the first two months about 66 percent
within three to four months 76 percent
in proven to about 80 to 80 percent from
five to six months later
this is a simplified plotting the
recommended dose
by the environment genomics surface on
the x-axis versus the prescribed dose
okay
as a result the discussion of the paper
indicate that this is the first epidemic
Center
study that involve an interdisciplinary
approach the genotyping was done on a
very timely basis prior to the second
dose up to about 80 percent
and in the laboratory it averages about
one patient with genotype per day and
this of course is supplemented by
genotyping or other diagnostic
and it suggests also in the future PM
tipped in typing might help to solve the
turnaround time and the low sample run
Financial visibility consideration
showed that third party payers was
available for the council and genotyping
then your decision support was written
over the point thus the implementation
of the program showed that this Warframe
pharmaceutical Services feasible
recently uh last year there were a
couple of reports studies published in
England Journal the first Mantra here
the title is a recognized trial of
genotype guided dosing of Warframe in
this study 455 patients was a role where
a roadway that was diagnosis as well BT
it was a single blind study the
genotyping was done by point of care
testing technology the genotype zip2c9
and micro C1
and the conclusion is starting to show
far more genetic based on sale result in
the high percentages of time achieving
therapeutic islands are
the next study also in learning Journal
is entitled 35 agenda Services versus
the clinical aquifer for Warfarin dosing
and this study randomized about 1 000
patients including African American
there was a double Prime static about
three months this one from the first
study the previous one there was no
difference of solubility
and clinical guided dosing
the next one that we want to briefly go
over is planet and the number two drugs
and it also
would benefit from
harmogenomics and metabolomic
understanding and uh in 2010
Ryan Williams of English name for
example announced that FDA issue of
Black Box wanted they might not work for
some people due to genetics
and further products are supposed to
have what he meant was that he would
require a mediation of 2019
to convert it to the Active Metabolism
they are used in the laboratory of LC
nasback might be readily might be
readily
are used to characterize the active
metabolize this however requires some
stabilization on the left hand side
shows planets Erin jocks on the right
hand side it shows the Active Metabolism
and there was some concern about uh the
products investigation as shown by
recent newsletter I don't know or the
biology produce publishing elsewhere
in another area of acting uh development
is the use of farm genomics in pain
medicine this is a article published it
was published in pain medicine used in
2013.
and it talks about genetic testing in
pain pain medicine
and a quote that admission would test
who treat pain have note that the
response to opioids varies widely among
patients the opioid those requirement
varying in the clinical setting by as
much as for info
Dr titani from Universal Louisville and
his colleagues have recent publication
around this area here the first one was
published in 2013 and this article by Dr
dutane and is called it looked at the
role of hydro more form and opioid
receptor in pain relief with hydrocodone
impose C-section patients this was
published in pain physician a more
recent publication early this year
appeared in clinical chemistry actor and
I'd like to show you the summary of this
finding the study entitled title proton
impose operator personalized pain
management poly drugs or drugs
to this study recognized that
hydromorphone
exert the energetic effect it 710 times
more important in the model to
recertifying things also 100 times more
than Hydrocodone so the object could be
studied is to determine whether simply
stereotype and serum Hydromorphone
levels are covered for some of the
relatability in pain relief scene with
hydrocodone in a cohort of Woodland
policy sections
the protocol included 156 both C-section
patients they were 18 to 45 years old
increasing criteria are listed as well
as the exclusion criteria
certainly application
was devaluated by bas4 looking at side
effects and supplemented by the
treatment called 800 milligram Ibuprofen
why those signs were recorded and five
ml of blood was obtained for the
patients and genotype for 17 steps and
touching the rearrangement the drug
concentration was determined by LCM
aspect and the data recognized
statistically
ticket to show from that paper the
percentage of extensive intermediate
Auto Rapid and product metabolizer for
this patient group was c26
and table 2 of this paper showed an
impression or pain index on CM
Hydromorphone for this 156 patients in
particular it shown the significant
relationship between Hydro morphine
much more so than Hydrocodone
then hydrocodone
and also known hydrocodone
table one of this paper shows a
demographic of this patient whoever and
the there were four columns showing the
age
the pain index and other information
just a side effect and the CM level of
the four phenotypes Auto Rapid
metabolism
extensive metabolizing intermediate
metabolizer and also the print
metabolites
for the autographic metabolizer a height
or nothing level
is about 7.1 and it decreases to 5.5 for
the extent metabolism to 3.9 in the
intermediate metabolizer the clean
metabolizer only 0.7
the next presentation shows the
relationship of to sick phenotype
as shown by autographic
extensive intermediate and pro
metabolized in relation to plasma
Hydromorphone concentration
in other words
in the case of outer rapid metabolizer
because the increased expression of 626
mni more hydrocodone was convertible to
hydrogen water
correspondingly higher than
that of extensive metabolizer and that
are the intermediate metabolizer and
in the case of poor metabolizer a very
small percentage of conversion
Dr judany was able to show that
c26 in this patient with genotyping
would
very consistence with the general
populations
608 I would show up in metabolizer were
African-Americans
and 507
Pro metabolizes
record patients
the first study according to the group
to demonstrate that technically is
related to Hydromorphone contemplation
and then this is a very nice study we
minimize variable in cohort
the last drug groups that we want to
look at is the the possible use of Home
mix for in the metabolism personally in
the United States there are five major
presence standing there was very well
established Cycles foreign
in terms of ramaphomet the calcium Mass
Spec Master procedure such as the word
Outreach several years ago in the
journal chromatopically
show a sensitive connotation of
cellulitimus which is randomizing and
our our memos by healthy natural Mass
Effect and on the left hand side it
shows the protocol of using a very fast
and simple technique using about 200
micro liter whole blood
and about 50 microliter let's
supplemented after precipitation was
then injected into the LCM aspect for
connotation on the upper right hand side
it shows it's possible to quantify
up to down to about problem one this
patient nanogram Prime l or breath a
license and about 0.8
elements
so this shows the
pharmacologic study
and with a lot of study sense uh center
around the possible use of Pharma
genomic improve immunosuppressing
therapy
and some steady demonstrated homogeneity
may be helpful to maximize efficacy and
minimize toxicity for example for every
time you say for a patient who have a
62385 star 3 and start with it might
require lower dose and however
another city demonstrated that a key
rejection
was not affected by c35 staff
expressions
and the side effect another study number
four shows that it might be predicted by
c3as or The receptors and finally
p450
oxy Star 28 and f356 this this position
in pediatric linear transfer it shows
that for Pediatric patients which
express
c385
and about 18 percent
lower the dose concentration by result
and this study was published in TDM this
year
page 232 to 8.
so at this point in time
there are a lot of interesting
observation about the possible use of
rubber genomics for human separency
therapy TDM
and then other possibility is the use of
building elements and study who is the
published by blue cloud in 2003
I looked at about 32 window transplant
patients
and 17 of these patients will develop a
skin rejection 15 did not and Dr Clark
was able to use a technique or selling
top Mass atomically to identify
those proteoly Peaks and therefore
suggest that biomarker panel might
enhanced diagnostic performances
and earlier last year our patient was
shown
foreign
and his was given a
Palm transplant and uh also before the
transplant it was able to have
developmental transplant with donor and
the surgeon stated that it will only
take one entire rejection medication
instead of the usual triple cocktail
and therefore entertain uh in the future
unless
combination drug therapy for
immunosuppressants
Clerk
and finally I will write a notepad the
future of functionality the resource and
article a tutorial published by McCarthy
last year it focuses on functionality
past present and future we focus on
ethical issue worrying about the family
access to treatment in African groups
the major challenges include how
predictive is from genetic the
infrastructure needed such as the Big
Data the interpretation and also
indicator data set in the future this
large data sample had to be interpolated
it might benefit for the Next Generation
sequencing and the artist also suggests
that I'm economic might be complementary
the proteomics gene expressions and also
other molecular Imaging and achieving
better drug therapy
so these are the areas of Interest
so in conclusion I'd like to suggest
that the laboratory is reading a
position to help the practice of
personalized medicine in particular by
offering personalized laboratory
medicine
we expect that this trend will be needed
it will help from educating the medical
students medical schools and also
updating this information to practicing
missions to be aware and hopefully more
accepting the practice by using
pharmaceutical performance
the public awareness is already gaining
as we have seen from television coverage
and also the recent very encouraging
harm transplant during first month is
also a major concern
uh the study done by UIC show there was
some possibility of reversing from
Warframe about genomics at this point in
time it might categorize functionality
still emerging and usually require a
combination of genes such as in the case
of Warframe and pain management is an
area where Pharma genetic actually might
demonstrate a lot of potential to help
the patient achieve pain management
therapy optimal dosing with
pharmaceutics and finally in a
characterized from genomics a strategy
of development and pharmacist metformin
has emerging and but those of you would
like to receive credit please go to this
website and and thank you very much for
attention and I'll be glad to answer any
questions
um
foreign
there are now two questions appearing on
my questions and answer
screen of my presentation the first
question is
what is your opinion about a
relationship of snips and pharmaceutics
at this point in time there are a lot of
information demonstrating that Snips can
be used to correlate to the phenotype
for drug therapy and I was a character
also that
such as in case of warframes usually
more a combination of snips the
characterization and also correlating
the phenotype so with the exception for
example in a study shown on pain
management of hydro
hydrocodone and hydromorphone where only
one team was done uh you most likely in
the future work for example what was
done for the world and study including
the a combination of three snakes uh for
example the slip of 2C
2019 icon C1 as well as for F2
the next question number two
uh the question is
asking about family genetic sampling is
often part of
fim early phase clinical trial
so this be mandatory
summative biomarkers
that I refer to
at this point in time I would like to
answer this second question as follow
whether or not
pharmacogenetic is going to be part of
the other phase clinical trial is very
depending on the pharmaceutical company
when they are doing the discovery to lay
phase Discovery in translating the the
biomarkers whether or not they will
become a company
print will be terminated in
it it is
beginning to appreciate the emerging use
of companion Diagnostics
the third question is can you explain to
me what is a pharmaceutical metabolomic
uh
in pharmacologic is really an extension
of a definition presented by NIH in that
it talks about the study of the various
metabolism it's really important
definition of drug metabolism
and because metabolomic as we understand
from the definition of NIH also includes
study of drugs and Drug metabolism
therefore we can also characterize the
national apparent just metabolite as a
third understanding metabolism
question number four
what is the percentage of patients using
Pharmaceutical
routinely for pain management uh this is
a very important question and I
apologize I really don't have an answer
uh perhaps one way to look at that would
be we understand about 75 percent of the
drugs approved in the United States
involve polymorphic enzyme so a percent
certain percentage of this uh 75 percent
money more important of enzyme drug
therapy which might be used for pain
management so it will be a fraction of
that percentage the final question is
the
insertion does not show cmu4 for MDS why
not and I think if I may refer the
question to the programmer and
also
if the last question is if time
permission is disconnected
the final question is if time could be
saying more about the Hopkins job
repairs on the military veterans were
aided by immunosuppressants and and this
is a very hard Asia Advance major
advance in transplant in geography by
bone marrow transplantation Dr Lee and
the other surgeon uh we're able to use
only one drug inside cocktail are the
details of the job therapy are preaching
fire departments thank you very much
I think uh at this point in time I think
I might have
attempt to answer the sixth question
that I was posted they were posted
and if there are further questions feel
welcome to email me directly the
address which I'm happy clap to to
respond to your Eco in the future and
thank you so much for your attention
thank you